today we're going to be talking about
ubiquitous computing
um people a lot of people also call it
ubicomp so i'm going to be using the
phrase ubicomp
as well as ubiquitous computing so
whenever you hear me say you become
that's just a compression
of ebooks ubiquitous computing because
as you can tell
it's quite hard to say ubiquitous a lot
so that's why people say you become
okay so you become so is this the idea
of computers being everywhere
or is it is it more than that there's a
kind of vision associated with
ub comp which is all about
i guess sort of disappearing of
computers or at least
the idea of computers not being kind of
visible to us not necessarily that we
can't see them but they're effectively
invisible in our kind of practices so
when we kind of go and
do stuff in the world we're interact
interacting with and using computing
technologies all the time
but the ways in which we're doing it
we're not really focusing on on the
on the technology itself and it's quite
in contrast to kind of how people talk
about
people say using mobile phones and just
being completely focused on the phone
and so on so the idea of the vision of
ubicomp is obvious of this kind of
world of um seamless interactions with
technology that just simply uh
help us get stuff done
one of the founders of ubiquitous
computing um or ubicomp as well now
call it was mark weiser and he talked
particularly about
calm computing so this idea that there's
not this kind of frenetic
activity interacting with all these
devices and managing all this kind of
digital stuff
rather i'm just simply able to do things
in life in a kind of calm way and it
just so happens that i use technology to
get those things done
way back in the midst of time in the
early days of computer file we did
something called
a video called what is a computer i
think it was with
professor tom rodden and we were talking
about the ideas of computers being in
credit cards and computers
being in all sorts of places that you
don't even realize
things like the internet of things i
suppose we're talking about here but
it's not just as you say that it's also
the fact that
our interaction with them is not
something that we even necessarily
consider
is that is that about right well the
kind of the idea of
ubicomp turns on is that
um it's embedded into everyday life
so in much the same way that we don't
really
think necessarily about some of the
infrastructures in our house
that kind of enable our house to go to
work properly so i mean
an example would be like something like
the heating perhaps a lot of time you
don't think about the heating but as
soon as it breaks down it suddenly
becomes
manifest and kind of very much visible
even though most of the time you're not
really you know just kind of it just
sort of works most of the time
one of the ways to understand you become
where it comes from is to
understand that mark wiser was um
reacting against
what was very popular at the time so
he developed ubicomp in the late 80s
and early 90s virtual reality was a big
deal at the time it was a kind of first
wave of vr vr is doing this thing where
we're taking people into the machine in
a kind of very absorbing way and
if you've been around anyone using a vr
headset you'll know that it's very
difficult to
communicate with them and to have any
kind of shared experience
and so ubicomp was about taking the
computing and putting it into the world
embedding it into
everything to avoid that problem
of being absorbed into the machine so
it's very much kind of
of the view that technology should
let us get the things done that we need
to and not get in the way and so vr is
very much the opposite that where the
technology becomes
the focus of attention so it must be
seen in the context that historical
context the reaction against
um against vr really was mark weiser at
somewhere like mit
or or one of these places berkeley or
something so mark weiser
was uh kind of one of the it's best
known basically
as someone who was at xerox park now
park is palo alto research center so
xerox park was a division of xerox to
the
photocopier company who are still around
park was very famous for
establishing some of the core uh
components i guess for elements of
computing which are all very familiar
with now
park developed what looks like one of
the first pcs
effectively called the xerox alto you'll
see
it kind of looks like a desktop computer
it's got a keyboard got a mouse
it's a kind of well-known story that
steve jobs
went to park and had a look around
and saw the alto and interface
and took a bunch of things from it and
implemented it into
apple's range of machines and kind of
famous for doing so but you know you saw
something
that seemed like it kind of worked
really well and as any sensible person
should do
uh take that and use it in some kind of
way
so the history of um xerox park is
really important because of
because of that aspect i mean there's
other aspects of the alto which are
important like
networking and so on crucially during
the kind of late 80s and early 90s sort
of bringing us up to
mark wise's time xerox park was
developing
a load of different sorts of
technologies around things like
improvements in sort of networking
mobility
so sort of reducing sizes of things
making devices more mobile
um improving kind of their networking
capabilities
um dealing with issues around power
those sorts of things they were
developing all these different
technologies
and one of the issues was that mark
weiser saw was that there was no
coherent vision of all these different
technologies and how they might fit
together and he had this
um this way of thinking which brought
them together and that's what
birthed this idea of ubi comp mark
weiss's vision
was to take uh or the ubcom vision was
to take all these different
disparate bits of technology that were
being developed like you know wi-fi
networking and
better power management and more
powerful computing and display
technologies and all these sorts of
things
and bring them together into this vision
of ubiquitous computing which was about
you know computing being everywhere um
with you on your old times uh in the
woodwork so to speak as he put it
um embedded into buildings embedded into
you know
all sorts of places vehicles those sorts
of things
in a way it's kind of partly like the
world well elements of it are kind of a
bit like the world we're living in now
in the sense of
you know cars have extremely
sophisticated
management systems some cars are
connected to the internet
all times we have
internet of things technologies in our
homes so smart
bulbs smart heating systems whatever it
might be
we also have devices we carry around um
with us you know all
in all places so there's many ways in
which the
uh vision that he created of ubicomp
actually is kind of with us today today
certain elements of it so it's
although at the time it was massive yes
worth emphasizing how
how ambitious it was as a vision at the
time given that
you know talking about the late 80s um
there's no sense in which everyone had a
desktop pc at that point necessarily at
all
so it's a very very different world i
think that's if anyone's you know people
who are watching us have to really
understand if they weren't around then
they have to understand how much of a
different world it was and
um and how much of a kind of visionary
person he needs to be to bring the stuff
together
there's another aspect that's important
about bringing all those technologies
together
and that was a kind of to do with the
relationship between
park itself and xerox now as with any
and there's a story about the demise of
the
corporate um research lab which we can
probably talk about in another video but
um as with any kind of corporate
research lab or any kind of facility
like this he needs to justify
his existence to um to xerox
and one way to justify the development
of these very interesting technologies
was to say well actually part of a
bigger vision
and the vision was ubicomp
and so that so not just it wasn't just
that it had a
purely had a function in terms of the
kind of computer science elements but
also
this kind of um element of of how do you
justify this work
it actually occurring even at all so
i think you know he's a really important
figure because he brings together all
these things and then obviously that
leads to
this idea of internet of things which is
nowhere near as sophisticated in its
vision
as mark wise's original but there's no
way it would really exist without the
idea of ubicomp
if you want to read a core text about
you become
you can read his really famous 1991
scientific american article
called the computer for the 21st century
it's not a hugely technical
bit of writing so i'd encourage everyone
to go and have a look at it it kind of
lays out this vision
the ubicomp vision very clearly about
this world
um in which we live in this kind of
ubicomp world all these different
sense technologies different bits of
computing embedded into everything
also you know goes through all the
different challenges that are associated
with this because
we could talk at length about the some
of the issues that it brings up
so if we're doing ubiquitous computing
we suddenly have issues around things
like
as mentioned already power becomes a
real problem how do you power all these
devices sensors
how do you collect sensor data and then
make sense of it
at all because there's all this stuff
flying around in terms of the data
you're collecting
how do you network stuff how do you
ensure continuous provision of
networking services these are all major
problems still now obviously
how do you get the adequate data science
stuff
to do the inference to make sure you
understand the data you're getting back
and then act on it
how do you determine things like context
these are really critical problems and
what the kind of interaction techniques
that you need to build
to enable people to actually interact
with these um always on always with you
type devices or
devices that are embedded into
non-standard things like you know you're
not expecting
the wall to have a computer embedded
into it what's the form of interaction
that you might
uh need to enable someone to interact
with a wall in an appropriate way that's
not a
trivial thing to work out i mean it took
a long time just to get to you know
this sort of thing right um many many
different prototypes were made to get to
the mouse the surprising amount of work
in something we now take for granted
did mark weiser see his vision fulfilled
what happened
mark wise unfortunately died in 1999 so
he died quite young um and uh
you know so so he he would have seen the
some of the fruits of what he'd created
in terms of vision
um i guess in terms of things like
miniaturization
and increased networking you know
improvements in that technology and all
those sorts of things
but but i really think um you know
he'll be missing out on the internet of
things that we see now and
there's a very direct line between that
as i said between that and
you become so i think there was a lot
more to come
basically that that he never saw
unfortunately
i i would argue here that the way that
the internet of things has developed uh
in a kind of ramshackle away
from various different manufactures is
far from his vision
by from what i understand how do you go
about testing a system
like this when you're coming up with it
from nowhere and
these aren't kind of devices you can
ship off to somebody to have a play with
how do you go about making sure it does
stuff that you wanted to do
when they were building these different
devices they talked about building
technologies at different scales they
had a very small scale post-it note
scale
through to a kind of ipad size scale
through to a kind of whiteboard size
scale
and they kind of experiment with
different technologies have been
involved in
building those things and making them
work um in order to
test them um they actually use
themselves
in their own work they sort of ate their
own dog food
so to speak in working with them they
understood more about what it meant to
live in this way
with those technologies so that way in
which they test it out themselves was
very very important
for um the kind of ubicomp vision and
establishing
the ubicomp vision for for others um and
you know making it um seem like it's
taken seriously which is
we're so serious about this technology
we're just going to use it ourselves and
i think at the time that wasn't
necessarily
really one of those kind of practices
that people would generally engage in
they'll generally be
um perhaps engaging users
other people in in trials for a specific
short amount of time
and measuring various facets of of those
of those trials those experiments
drawing very badly here
and so on so you'd have two sets of
pulses one delayed from the other
it's what we call quadrature encoding we
can actually derive from that
1990 something or other this was
this big crunch coming up that we're
going to run out of ip addresses any